la parole est à madame valérie boyer
pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le premier ministre j'associe à
ma question mes collègues des
républicains membres de la commission
des affaires sociales en suspendant
immédiatement leur grève le vendredi 13
novembre et en se mettant à la
disposition de nos compatriotes nos
professionnels de santé ont fait leur
devoir avec patriotisme responsabilités
je souhaite plus que jamais les
féliciter car ils sont restés mobilisés
et le sont toujours
pour garder la vie quand bien même il
n'en restait qu'un souffle pourtant ce
soir nous examinons un texte qui fait
l'unanimité des professionnels de santé
contre lui la loi santé la loi santé
nécessitait méritait pourtant un
moratoire alors que le monde de la santé
est en colère et dénoncer réforme faite
sans concertation vous répondez que
leurs craintes ne sont pas fondées
un an après la première lecture de votre
projet rien n'a changé on impose le
tiers payant généralisé aux médecins en
privent les cliniques privées des
dispositifs de missions d'intérêt
général on malmène l'industrie
pharmaceutique et les pharmaciens on
veut supprimer l'ordre des infirmiers et
je ne m'étendrai pas sur les veillées
funéraires les réseaux fermés les
laboratoires qui certains analyses ou et
le patient qui devait être au coeur du
dispositif
vous allez même jusqu'à proposer des
salles de shoot pendant que certains
députés socialistes portent l'étendard
de la légalisation du cannabis
vous comprendrez pourquoi le
mécontentement est général
mon groupe sera là pour défendre les
professionnels de santé nous verrons
avec le vote solennel de la semaine
prochaine qui sera à leurs côtés
alors que la france est encore en deuil
votre gouvernement persiste dans la
division en maintenant la discussion sur
la loi santé monsieur le premier
ministre
l'unité nationale ça ne se décrète pas
ça se construit
si cette loi est si important pour votre
gouvernement dans le contexte douloureux
que nous connaissons ne devrait-elle pas
rassembler plutôt que fragiliser et
divisé
merci madame la députée la parole comme
madame la ministre des affaires sociales
et
santé merci madame la présidente des
dames et messieurs et les pulls et
madame la députée boyer oui notre
système de santé a besoin d'être
confortés et moi je n'ai qu'une priorité
et madame la députée l'excellence du
système de français au service de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et cet
objectif là c'est cela qui anime le
projet de loi qui a été débattue déjà il
ya plusieurs mois en première lecture et
qui ne comporte au moment de la deuxième
lecture aucune mesure nouvelle alors
dire que tous les français grâce au
tiers payant doivent pouvoir accéder à
des soins de qualité sur le territoire
c'est un enjeu de santé publique
et c'est un enjeu de justice sociale
dire madame la députée dire madame la
députée que le service public
hospitalier qui a montré le meilleur de
lui-même doit être reconnue et doit être
porté fièrement dans la loi oui c'est
quelque chose qui existe et que j'assume
et pour autant contrairement à ce que
vous faites madame la députée moi je
n'oppose pas les uns aux autres et nous
n'opposons pas les uns aux autres parce
que tout l'enjeu
tout l'enjeu précisément au lieu de
faire que l'hôpital il travaille avec la
médecine devine que les passions soit
accueillie par l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé que les médecins
travaillent avec les infirmières et
c'est cela qui guide l'action du
gouvernement
une exigence de prévention pour faire en
sorte que la santé des jeunes s'améliore
alors que nous savons que c'est un des
points faibles dans notre pays
faire en sorte que notre système de
santé restent toujours au rendez-vous de
l'excellence excellence reconnu à
l'échelle internationale et que cette
excellence elles puissent bénéficier à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens alors le
débat va avoir lieu madame la députée
mais ce débat il se fait dans l'intérêt
des français dans l'intérêt des
professionnels il n'y a pas d'un côté
ceux qui défendent les professionnels et
de log ceux qui défendent les patients
il y a une politique service de la
france et du sexe du système de santé
français
merci madame la ministre la parole et
tamada